so
the word of the day
is tall
so here we go 10 minutes to write a joke
using the word tall uh feel free to ride
along uh try to create your own joke
using the word tall
or we can write this together as i go
through this brainstorming exercise and
i'm going to try to talk
through it as well
to um
to try to give you a real time breakdown
or
of like what i'm thinking why i'm
making certain decisions and thinking
certain ways
cool beans
all right so
that being said my friends
ten minutes on the clock
guinness is here evelyn yay
he is don't worry he'll be he'll be
making a bigger cameo here in a second
um
we're gonna do this writing exercise so
how cool i'm excited about this i think
this is really cool
which is the whole point of hot breath
is um what do you wish existed and then
put it into existence
so
where the day is tall
we're gonna do 10 minutes on the clock
for some reason i'm like trying to give
myself more room on here which i don't
know why i'm doing that we'll just leave
it be
i'm like distracting myself from
actually having to write the joke so
here we go
10 minutes on the clock using the word
tall
and here we go
so basically what i like to do with
writing a joke
is um i like to write the date this is a
great pl way to start june right june
1st so the word of the day is tall so
it's
i like to um just associate whatever i
can think of with tall so i mean for me
you know i'm actually tall but what
comes to mind to me is like all right i
was husky
growing up and then i got tall my mom
called up my middle school middle so
maybe there's something there
and for this exercise i don't like to
use material i've done before i don't
like to um i like to try to go fresh and
raw with it so so tall um
asking to reach
things part of joke writing is finding
the inverse finding the surprise
misdirects so maybe it's asking other
people to pick up things
and i do very shorthand when i write my
jokes like some of it's just like
intuitive like asking pickup so that
means asking people to pick up things
for me but you know
it's kind of writing in your own
language so
tall
b-ball
asking me if i play basketball
people always ask me that because i'm
tall
i was tall and unathletic
so maybe there's something there
um tall
ducking
under
doors um
airplane seats
tall
clothing
which is why i love eddie bauer because
they have tall sizes maybe there's
something with eddie bauer and we're
always going for something personal
we're always trying to find something
that's like
personal and unique to you so
honestly i think it's already sticking
out to me as i've been brainstorming for
about two minutes here
is um
tall and being tall and unathletic
i think is a funny uh juxtaposition
so now we want to find a premise so
basically what i'm what i want to set up
we want to have a setup premise and a
punchline permit so i want to set up
to make people think
i'm athletic and then the punch line
is that i'm not
i'm not athletic
so now what are setups that could say
i'm athletic
and thinking of how we can weave the
word tall into this
so it could be
being tall
made
me great
at
basketball
and already a misdirect that comes to
mind
is on
you know xbox you know there's a silly
misdirect there being told made me great
at basketball
um
i grew up tall and athletic
i'm sure y'all can read this doesn't all
this track isn't that all that in very
clear blatant english
so another part of my handwriting is um
[Music]
tall and athletic it's like they can't
steal your jokes they can't read them is
what i would tell people when they would
see my set lists and stuff so grew up
tall and athletic
another thing that says i'm athletic
i um always picked first
what else is with athleticism other
scholarships
just sports you know whatever comes to
mind i'm athletic scholarship sports
nba
um
scholarship sports nba
how tall specificity
so six foot four
which anyone that's met me in real life
doing any of the hot breath shows the
first thing they say is oh he is tall ah
so being 64 gave me an advantage in
sports
um
grew up tall and athletic all right
we're coming up on five minutes so
usually within the first five minutes i
like to find a premise
that i'm working on
to then misdirect so right now i'm
working on i'm athletic and then the
misdirect is i'm not athletic so the
only real joke we have right now is
being tall
made me great at basketball
on xbox
there's a slight misdirect but there's
no real correlation between being tall
and xbox um
being tall
and i'm never married to an idea either
though if something else jumps into my
head i'm always willing to like pull an
audible as well
people always ask me how tall i am
um being tall makes me great at sports
i like something with a scholarship
something with the word scholarship is
singing to me
give me an advantage in sports
so what can tease being unathletic being
white
being white and 6'4
b-ball all-star
i feel pressure here i got to come up
with something
i'm athletic i'm not athletic so what do
i say i'm not athletic
uh
bench
bombing
injury
how's the air up
[Music]
there um
[Music]
being 6'4
made me and if y'all have any um
ideas for the premise i'm working on
here feel free to spitball them here
and um
feel free to spitball them here
in the chat so i'm coming up on two and
a half minutes oh
being white in six four made me a
basketball all-star
scholarship i like a scholarship
maybe
but maybe it's not basketball maybe it's
just athletic
people always ask me how tall i am
tall enough to see over your judgment
so it could be um people ask me how tall
i am tall enough to see over your
judgment
oh gosh 60 seconds
um
as a tall white man basketball was a
no-brainer
um
being tall made me great at basketball
what is basketball hoop
goal
great at sports
being tall and white
great at sports
on xbox
oh the time's up oh my gosh that was
difficult and very nerve-wracking to be
writing this
in front of all of y'all
so basically
i mean at the baseline the premise being
i'm athletic and then the punch premise
being i'm not athletic
being tall and white made me great at
sports on xbox so
this setup
is
expressing
that i'm athletic
you see so when you hear being tall and
white made me great at sports
so
that does express
the premise of
i'm athletic
and then
the punchline
does express
i'm not athletic
so being tall and white made me great at
sports on xbox